ciao a tutti ragazzi e prevenuti
avessero video sono fa vj devo per forza
avviarlo al solito modo posso cliccare
l'icona così per avviar non lo devo
avviare al solito moda avviamolo al
solito modo li mortacci mia ciao tesoro
non ho detto ancora un cazzo ciao come
stai
[Musica]
è una domanda semplice non è che ti ho
chiesto quanti di spazio e ti ho chiesto
come stai sorella non ci deve pensare
regata orc aveva come cazzo stai a zia
non ho capito ci sei o ci sei come stai
forchetta io invece preferite che
morissi però è un altro disco a vitro
west per cortesia ai una sveglia e sti
cazzi tre campane lo avvio così perché
non è che posso fare una vita decente io
devo andare anche a girarmi i pollici
con consigli ci manca solo quel devo
fare un episodio solo con siri e
insultarla dall'inizio alla fine cosa
che ho già fatto ma lo devo rifare la fa
partire ma oggi funziona qualcosa deve
andare tutto storto ragazzi facciamo a
solitario le carte che è un gioco serio
almeno quella fi
sì grazie gesù siamo alla fine del video
ma siamo partiti meno male meglio tardi
che mai deve anche lo 10 che sono pochi
anzi no neanche otto ne mancano 8 non so
contare che non so contare siri che mi
rende stupido partiamo col primo ne
mancano otto sono pochi
zavos oval si spera che sia una bella
signora almeno perché se no
prime muscolari quindi o è una bella
signora oppure shaarawy uno dei due enti
è uomo in pantofole che guarda alcuni
nel monitor
hai voglia di fare qualcosa ne
incontriamo guarda alcuni per tutta la
vita
certo io clicco sul tipo del tipo
scoreggia cosa che non ha senso la tenda
perfetto quando non sai che fare
interface quest devi trascinare il dito
però dove cassano trascina stato da lui
dio che c'è il suo successo
ma come credo come ho fatto non ho
capito cliccato qualcosa ragazze non ho
capito cosa ma è caduto un missile sulla
luna giusto ditemi se è normale europee
già in pose era quello del dell'ice
baker challenge che tipo adesso mi
diceva che challenge tv ma che cazzo lì
dove avevo fatto e mi ricordo più è
passato un secolo
raga non mi ricordo più veramente qui mi
sono fatto avevo chiamato come si faceva
a portare sul bidone devo fare l'ice
bike challenge col bidone della
spazzatura però non capito come farlo
come si sposta ghiaccio
ok tra che bisogna trascinare in
famiglia di giò trascinate molti di voi
mi hanno chiesto come si fa l'altro è
grazie zio chiedono come si fanno i
livelli che a volte non si capisce come
di farci basta che trascinate il dito
non so dove ma trascinate bike challenge
che cosa minchiate rinite l'ho fatto
ragazzi condividi i tuoi progressi no
grazie guarda non voglio far sapere a
mia nonna che gioca trofei space grazie
per avermelo chiesto per questo è
l'intelligenza ragazzi casco bene io in
quell'intelligenza di oxford sommario
son bari della houston o questa canzone
qua conosco è quello del video no adorni
venne già ce l'hai piccolo che lo zio
[Musica]
pasticcia fatta già fatta
no non ce l'ho fatta cosa ho fatto non
ho veramente capito che cosa dovrei fare
però devo renderlo colorato no cosa
faccio dai regali fare un difficile
gioco di merda schiaccia caso insieme ci
sarà una possibilità su un milione che
funzioni prima o poi a minare il suo
stesso guardando non è un video non sto
guardando a video sto guardando sanremo
sto guardando sanremo dopo guardando
sanremo per capire come si suona la
musica non è non erano mica le soluzioni
ma che cazzo che chi vi credete che io
sia che vada a vedere i video ma che
miscredente mi è venuto un illuminazione
perché non clicchiamo qui ecco sosta
trojan o capita sta cosa però andiamo
avanti ragazzi cè un cesso o scaricato
un troll fantastici non ci manca solo
quello guarda a chicago cavo
innumerevoli volte finché non prendo il
volo era una gomma da masticare nascosto
nella tasca va bene ma non siamo già
fatto a questo livello
volete farci ecco infatti ci avrei
scommesso che decollava per
ok basta basta basta da visita grazie
grazie
cazzo vuole io ti ho visto tizio azzi e
mac non decisamente non è l'uomo che
ballava tutto ovunque balla anche a casa
ti fa vj ho trovato la gallina l'ultimo
anno in 10 10
sono tutte cosa ho vinto ho vinto cazzo
quindi se adesso vado dal mcdonald e vi
faccio vedere che ciò le 10 galline
militano le crocchette di pollo gratis
devo fare è triste perché si triste
perché è triste c'è qualcosa li deve
cadere in testa sto cristiano non è
perché balla male ma porca eva non si
può vederlo trascinando a carissimo
qualsiasi cosa che non è che posso
passare la vita e quindi era era era
finta la cosa cioè era un paesaggio
finto non lo sapevo bene grazie io che
poi sono intuitivo nelle cose
l'avevo proprio capito subito credetemi
che bella che sei senza braccia zia una
cassetta un troll fea il trophée
spaventa tutti telefono cassetto al
telefono cassetta telefono cassetta a
devo continuare a farli vivere
no kat o una cosa devo fare una riuscita
a far manguel un deficiente nell'anima
perso vinto come cosa ho fatto non ho
capito grazie frate stavolta mi ha mai
colpito tanto queste minecraft cioè
minecraft su troppo face quest in poche
parole va bene devo trovarli tutti in
poche parole un equa l'altro e sulle
scale sulle scale sul sul mio culo
eccolo lo trovai a caso devo cliccare a
caso ho già capito quanti ce ne devono
essere ancora non trovati quattro
ragazzi usa devo fare
eccolo ho trovato qualsiasi gioco faccio
alla fine cadeau su minecraft perché non
c'è verso da il sig
come come cazzo fatto come possibile
dopo 14 anni e mezzo di vita siamo
arrivati all'ultimo livello non ci posso
mai credere che anche tanto silenzioso
tra che per lo sguardo non è certo
l'unico è il più bello unicorno che
abbiamo visto in tutta la mia vita anche
una voce sensuale riammetterlo c'è una
leva gli unicorni podio mista stuprano e
sono propenso ma non lo vedete il senso
neanche io cosa devo fare
lo cavalco a vado futuro unicorno per
fermare in corner e incornate vi
incornate fa qualcosa è stato un corno
cornutazze tutti quanti ma che fanno
bene posso entrare grazie una macchina
su una barca su un triciclo ad olio bene
perfetto ho vinto adesso ci sono una
donna una sola domanda a cosa cazzo
serviva l'unicorno in basso a destra chi
chiamerà perché non ho capito perché
erano ragazzi ho finito trasferisco e
strisce è stato veramente strano
ottenere altro gioco tra il fisco anche
un altro gioco di professore c'è un
altro 3 face quest chiama trophies
questa al lucky che giocherò nel
prossimo episodio ma per adesso ragazzi
ho finito tra face quest video memes che
è stato lunghi 40 cazzo di livelli
impossibile a cosa minchia serviva
l'altro unicorno me lo spiegate che cosa
prima il coso dell'unicorno e non vale a
dire che me lo devo infilarne al culo
quello già lo so chiudere video così è
qualcosa di orribile farò lo faccio lo
stesso perché ecco infatti credo ragazzi
spero che a video vi sia piaciuto e cosa
e cose vita vissuta sotto argomento è un
mi piace anche alla pagina di facebook
come nei video tratte una descrizione 06
dovresti discrete noi ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video ragazzi non posso fare io
e sta applicando una devo più aprire
nella v non è pronunciato insomma questo
mi rappresenta bene non posso chiudere
con telecomando perché sono solo un
bambino
però se volete mica go addosso se non
sono vestiti scrivere ci vediamo il
prossimo video beh ragazzi